[Music]
um there's a lot of spreadsheets
forgetting
yesterday
is
[Music]
okay
is
once every five days
now the person to ask about this people
that are in charge of this
thing is cbs cbs is in charge
they might be able to help
the problem
yes
yes
[Music]
uh
hello
alrighty
uh
okay
oh
[Music]
oh
oh my god
okay
check cbs
all right
two minute warning for the press
briefing two-minute warning
thank you
okay let's do this you ready yeah man
get this one right all right
alrighty then
it looks really
worst
[Music]
the other day
hi everyone
no guest today
good afternoon and happy thursday before
we get into questions
um and i promise ample time for
questions today i wanted to share
just a few updates with you first today
president biden signed two executive
actions that will begin to restore
and strengthen americans access to
quality affordable health care
specifically he directed agencies to
re-examine rules
and other policies that limits and limit
americans access to health care
and consider additional actions to
strengthen medicaid and the affordable
care act
so they can continue to provide access
to life-saving care for millions of
americans
as a result the department of health and
human services will open healthcare.gov
for a special enrollment period from
february 15th
to may 15th and just as a reminder the
prior administration only had it open
for six weeks so this is double
that length of time starting february
15th
americans without health insurance can
go to healthcare.gov and sign up for
health coverage often at little
or no cost the president also rescinded
the global gag rule
which bars international non-profits
that
international funding sorry let me state
this again which bars international
nonprofits that provide abortion
counseling or referrals from receiving
u.s
funding and he directed the department
of health and human services to take
immediate action to consider whether to
rescind
regulations under its title 10 family
planning program
these also of course build on the
actions the president has taken to put
equity at the heart of his
administration's response to covet 19.
second i wanted to update you on the
amendment being made to the public
readiness
and emergency preparedness act or prep
act declaration on the covid19
response hhs will amend the current prep
act declaration to permit
recently retired doctors and nurses to
administer covid19
vaccines and to permit anyone currently
licensed to vaccinate within their home
state
and to administer shots across state
lines so we've talked a lot in here
about
the need for not just vaccines but
vaccinators and this is an effort to
put more back vaccinators in the field
a number of states have already taken
action to ease licensing requirements to
expand the vaccinator workforce but this
nationwide access
action will make that easier across the
board the amendment will help us in our
vaccination efforts with a continued
goal of 100 million shots in 100 days
also today i just wanted to point you to
which you may have all seen
the statement by national economic
council director brian diese
about the quarterly gdp and weekly
unemployment claims
and finally a note on the vice
president's schedule today she's doing
local tv
interviews and meeting with editorial
boards in west virginia and arizona
to discuss the american rescue plan so
with that
go ahead thanks jenna i've got two one
form one domestic
um i wanted to ask you about the
pakistani supreme court's decision
to release the man that was convicted of
the killing of
uh journalist daniel pearl does the
white house have a response and are
there plans to
ask for his extradition to the us for a
trial
the united states is outraged by the
pakistani supreme court's decision to
affirm the acquittals of those
responsible for wall street journal
reporter daniel pearl's kidnapping
and brutal murder which shocked the
world's conscience in 2002
this decision to exonerate and release
sheikh and the other suspects in an
is an affront to terrorism victims
everywhere including in pakistan
we recognize past pakistani actions to
try to hold mr
pearl's murders murderers accountable
and we do note that as of right now
omar sheikh remains in detention in
pakistan under national security
authorities
but we call on the pakistani government
to expeditiously review its legal
options
including allowing the united states to
prosecute shake for the brutal murder of
an american citizen
and journalist and we're committed to
securing justice for daniel pearl's
family
and holding terrorists anywhere
accountable for their heinous
crimes and the state department i know
also just put out a statement
i wanted to ask about this flurry of
executive orders we've seen uh
president biden ran on a pledge to
restore unity
he promised on inauguration that he be a
president for all americans but since
he's gotten into office he's been
largely acting unilaterally i mean we
saw a record-breaking number of
executive orders
he has not yet met with lawmakers on
capitol hill and we're not even quite
sure who he's talking to on capitol hill
uh so what do you say to americans who
are watching
all of these executive orders and does
the white house think that this is the
best way to make policy considering
an opposing president could come back in
four years from now and erase all the
work he's done with the stroke of the
pet
well let me there's a lot to unpack
there so let me let me try my best um
first the president put forward a uh
large and bold covered relief package
1.9 trillion dollars that
is meant to address the challenges the
american people are facing and the dual
crises that
we are that the country is facing from
the pandemic
to an economic recession as a result um
that package
has the support of the majority of
americans according to
every poll that we have seen publicly
released
so i would say first that part of
unifying the country is addressing the
problems that the american people are
facing
and working to reach out to democrats
and republicans to do exactly that and
that's a public
members of congress many of them um he's
doing more calls today but he's doing
calls
regularly throughout the week and has
done them back to when he was
inaugurated and even before then but
he's also calling
democratic and republican mayors and
governors to talk to them about what
their needs are on the ground
so his objective as president is to
deliver on what he promised in his
inaugural address
governed for all of the american people
by focusing on
addressing the issues that people are
facing that aren't just hitting blue
states or red states aren't just hitting
democrats or republicans
but are crises that we are all facing
and i think the
the polls will tell you that people are
responding to that in terms of executive
actions
um he also ran with a commitment to take
steps immediately
to address uh the the pain and suffering
that the american people were feeling
and
that includes overturning some of the
detrimental
harmful and at times immoral policies uh
and
actions of the prior administration but
he's the first to tell you as he said
many times publicly
he's not going to take executive action
alone that's why he's put forward a
number of packages
that he's actively working with members
of both parties to move forward on
well if the issue is that congress is so
broken that he needs to
work quickly unilaterally to get some of
this done then does he support the move
towards reconciliation that senate
democrats are talking about right now
it's essentially
the same idea well i didn't say that
that was his point of view
those are your words not mine i would
say his view is actually that these
policies
the policies in his in his uh coveted
relief package
are policies that are not democratic or
republican
everybody wants their kids to go back to
school everybody thinks that there
should be more shots in the arms of
americans
everybody thinks that the american
people should get more relief and a
bridge in this period of time that is
such a challenge
so what he's saying is here's my
proposal here's how i think here's how
economists
uh medical experts health experts think
we can address these crises we all agree
are impacting all of our constituents
across the country let's have a
conversation about it that's what he's
doing
at the same time he's not going to delay
action
that can that would that would help
bring relief to the public
and help bring access to affordable
health care to
the american people help ensure women
have access to reproductive
uh reproductive uh health uh health as
well so
you know there are a lot of steps he's
taken over the past couple weeks he's
not going to delay actions that
require immediate um immediate action
that he can that he can bring that
relief immediately but he's also going
to work with congress he's proposed
multiple bills to do that
following up on that democratic leaders
on the hill appear to already be eyeing
reconciliation we heard
uh leader chuck schumer today saying
that they're moving ahead with or
without republicans
does this undermine your calls for
bipartisanship and are you urging them
to give this more time
well for we're all very close to this
here reconciliation and all the
terminology in washington
everybody who's watching may not be
reconciliation is a parliamentary
process it's a way to get legislation
through
it's a way to get relief to the american
people the president wants this to be a
bipartisan package
regardless of the mechanisms republicans
can still vote for a package
even it goes through if even if it goes
through with reconciliation there's no
blood oath anybody signs
uh they're able to sign to support it
regardless and
he wants this to be a bipartisan package
he's listening to democrats and
republicans we all are
to ensure that that's uh what it looks
like at the end of the day
but it doesn't seem that you can get
both the speed you want and the
bipartisanship
at the same time so which is the
priority i don't think that's true
we refute that notion you know these
challenges that the american public are
facing are urgent
uh people don't know how to plan to have
food on their table now
they're worried about whether their kids
can go back to school in a couple months
now
they're worried about getting the
vaccine now and those are issues that
republican elected officials are hearing
democratic
elected officials are hearing from their
constituents and we're confident
that people are going to listen to them
and come together to support a
bipartisan bill
and just one other question on covet um
the south african variant is now
been discovered to be here in the u.s
you of course have taken steps to
ban non-us citizens from south africa
from traveling here
uh that ban goes into effect on saturday
can you explain why why
saturday why not sooner uh
well the testing requirements um we put
in place that you noted um
uh were put in place for all departures
including south africa they take place
they they will be put into effect at 12
at
noon i guess noon on january 26th um
so this actually goes to into effect
friday night fair to saturday morning
close um and was put into place very
quickly over the course of a week to
stand up the necessary process i mean it
takes a little bit of time to put these
restrictions in place to
work with airlines work with a
regulatory authorities to get them in
place we did that as quickly as possible
and and before there was a reported case
of course because we've seen the reports
and we listened to health and medical
experts go ahead caitlin
so given that democrats have kind of
indicated they will move forward with or
without republican support would
president biden
sign a bill that only democrats voted
for
well we're not quite there that's
getting us a few steps of ahead of where
we are now
um he continues to believe that this can
be
will should be and will be a bipartisan
bill that receives support from
democrats and republicans
and he's having conversations with and
listening to leaders and members of both
parties to
assure that we get to exactly that place
but if we got to that place where only
democrats have voted for it
is he okay we'll have a conversation at
that point we're not there yet
okay second question on given all the
volatility surrounding wall street and
gangstop
what is the bike administration doing to
protect the average american investor
if there is going to be potentially a
major market correction coming
well the sec put out a statement um i
believe it was today or in the last 24
hours i should say we'd refer you to
that we're not going to have additional
comment from here
beyond just monitoring it has he had any
conversations with
economic officials about what's going on
we don't he's briefed by his economic
team frequently um but i don't have
anything more to read out for you
go ahead um is the sec doj or broader
administrations
administration
specifically looking at robinhood and
other platforms decision to prevent
retail investors from purchasing certain
stocks like gamestop
i don't have anything more on this aside
from to point you to the sec statement
one more question is the administration
working with uh majority leader uh
chuck schumer to push gary gensler's
nomination given the frenzy in the stock
market
well uh i i haven't i've not spoken with
our legislative team about
gary gensler's nomination specifically
but certainly
the president has spoken about the
urgency of getting his team in place to
address
the range of issues we're facing and i
don't think that would be any different
from mr gensler
um so that's brina uh thank you so much
uh first on the covet relief package
in order to cut a deal would president
biden be willing to
entertain a smaller package
well first and you didn't ask me this
but since there was some reporting this
morning i just want to take the
opportunity to be crystal clear
we're not looking to split the package
that is not a proposal from the white
house i talked to the president about it
this morning
that is not what uh our focus is or our
intention is
um and the reason is because
we are not going to put ourselves in a
place or anyone in a place where we're
choosing between
helping families to put food on the
table and
making sure kids go back to get back to
school or making sure kids kids
get back to school and getting a vaccine
in the arms of americans
now at the same time what the president
has conveyed to all of us and had during
his conversations with members of
congress is that
he's put his proposal out there he was
in the senate for 36 years um
he of all people appreciates the back
and forth the engagement the opportunity
to hear from members of all
sides on what they like what they don't
like things they think should be smaller
some have proposed things should be
bigger
there's of course lots of ideas no
member of congress is a wall flower
that are out there in public and
certainly that reflects the private
conversations as well
and you know there are areas for example
uh there has been some discussion of
can this be more targeted you know the
president believes that
and that based on his uh recommendations
of his account of economists and his
health
and economic experts this is a plan this
is a overall package and proposal that
is absolutely targeted for the people
who need it most but
uh he's happy to have a conversation
about that um and happy to have a
conversation about
um any component um uh that that people
are coming uh
coming at him with good ideas but our
focus is on
making it better and proving the package
as people have good ideas
we're open for business and open to hear
from members of congress on that
uh but we're not going going to do this
in a piecemeal way or break apart a big
package that's meant to address the
crisis we're facing
can you confirm that the administration
is actively
looking into expanding mandatory testing
for
domestic travelers here in the united
states and what other new domestic
requirements can you detail that might
be forthcoming well we had put out
just a couple of days ago as we talked
about earlier uh some
specific requirements on international
travel as you know
i don't have anything to preview for you
or predict on domestic travel
restrictions
our team is always evaluating and how to
keep the american people safe
go ahead thanks jen can you can you give
the american people
any hope that the vaccine supply is
going to go much over
10 million doses a week for the next
couple months
well as you know but in case people
watching don't know we made it the
president made announcement just two
days ago about
increasing the supply of vaccines to
ensure that we are getting
as much of the supply into the hands of
governors and elected officials as as we
can
to get the vaccine into the arms of
americans we're going to continue to
push as he said he's going to continue
to push
we will all continue to push but the
issue is not
just vaccine supply a big issue is
vaccinators
and the ability capacity to have people
who can put the vaccine into the arms of
americans
in communities and in neighborhoods to
to be able to do that and it's also
vaccine locations
so we increased we already made an
announcement less than 48 hours ago
about
increasing the vaccine supply going to
states he will continue to push
uh our goal is of course to continue to
increase uh in all of these areas the
main issue is supply
isn't it it's one of the issues uh
you know we will have we will be in a
place by this summer where we will have
uh enough supply for the public but that
doesn't ensure
that we that everybody will have had a
vaccine because we need to ensure we
have the materials to do
to distribute the vaccine the
vaccinators and qualified individuals to
literally put the shots in the arms of
americans places to do it
there this is why this is such a
herculean task because it requires so
many components
sanofi just announced that it has struck
a deal with pfizer to produce
125 million doses of the pfizer
vaccine but that's all going to the eu
and it's not going to start until this
summer
has the white house been talking to
domestic pharmaceutical companies about
doing something similar
more quickly well uh he did the
president did invoke the defense
production act as you all know
last week but we're not to quote dr
fauci because it's always
a good place to be we're not producing
shoes here we're producing
vaccines and we are
want to work very closely with the
manufacturers and
the companies that are the experts on
producing these to ensure they can do
exactly that it's not easy to start from
scratch in a new facility
we're very mindful of that and so right
now
we're certainly reviewing all options
but our focus is on
continuing to work directly with the
manufacturers and their facilities to
get the vaccines out the door
go ahead um thanks jen and nandita from
the voyagers news
um one question on the healthcare eo
today
um how many people does the white house
expect will sign up
during the supplemental time
period how many people are you expecting
will sign up for these insurance
programs
through the federal exchange well we
don't have a number to prevent to
predict for you um but the reason that
the president signed the executive order
today was because
um it felt essential at a time of a
pandemic when
millions of people are concerned about
their healthcare many far too many still
don't have access
to open up an expanded window for
americans to be able to apply and we
will have a robust public campaign
public
um paid media campaign to reach the
american people
and we'll be putting a lot of levers and
resources toward that but
i don't have a prediction for you in
terms of the numbers really no estimates
going in we're not going to do
predictions from here just as many
american people who don't have access
and currently are not on the exchange
that we can reach will be
our goal to reach and i had to follow up
on the on the markets and everything
that's happening with gamestop
uh you did mention i believe yesterday
um that the treasury secretary is
monitoring the situation and
she's kind of on top of it there have
been um some kind of concerns about
her previous engagements with citadel
and speaking fees
that she has received from citadel are
there any plans to have her recuse
herself from
advising the president on gamestop and
the whole robin hood situation
well just to be clear what i said was
that we have the treasury secretary is
now confirmed obviously we have a
broad economic team uh the sec put out a
statement
uh yesterday that i referred to but i
don't think i have anything more for you
on it other than
to say separate from the game stop issue
the secretary of treasury is one of the
world-renowned
experts on markets on the economy uh it
shouldn't be a surprise to anyone she
was
paid to give her perspective and advice
before she came into office
uh go ahead before she came in to be the
treasury secretary i should say go ahead
i have a couple of foreign policy issues
sure first one is on taiwan
a chinese defense ministry spokesman
said yesterday that
the chinese military activities and the
taiwan strait
is a necessary response to foreign
intervention
and that any efforts towards
independence needs
war does the administration believe that
beijing is
testing the us on the issue of taiwan
and how would you respond
well the good news is that my longtime
friend john kirby is giving a briefing
today
at the department of defense and i would
certainly refer you to him and any
comments he makes on this specific issue
do you have another question uh so on
i'm just
again following up uh secretary of
lincoln's statement yesterday
on the review of the sale of f-35s to
the united arab emirates and also
missiles to the saudis what is the
message of the administration to the
region
uh in terms of your position on the
abraham accords i understand the
president
is open to having more countries join
but how urgent
is it for the administration what would
be your strategy would you for example
continue the character and sticks
approach of the trump administration
uh well i know uh secretary blinken was
just confirmed yesterday i love having
all these cabinet members and colleagues
and places and agencies because
there's even more expertise out there
but um as you know
um we've recently paused um some arms
sales to ensure they meet our strategic
objectives including
how to end the conflict in yemen uh but
state uh
will be able to speak to it in greater
detail and as you also noted there's
going to be an ongoing review
of a range of policies including what
our engagement will be in the abraham
accords
in terms of the urgency how urgent is it
for the administration that more
countries sign off
well again this will be under the
purview of the state department i'm sure
they'll be speaking to it
and the secretary was just confirmed
earlier this week so we'll give him a
minute to figure out
where his pencils and pens are but
certainly it's important
an important issue and one that they
will be reviewing soon i'm sure
russia do you have anything else to add
now that the russian court has
uh rejected the appeal of alexey navalny
um anything else that you'd like to add
beyond what you've said
no as i as i noted the other day and as
was clear in the readout that we issued
of the president's call with president
putin
um he did not hold back in conveying his
uh concern uh and about uh the
treatment of alexia navalny and the
treatment of protesters and
um that is certainly something that will
be continued to be will continue to
communicate
uh at many levels with the russians go
ahead hi
uh two questions actually third i just
wanted to follow up on just on the
russia question
is there anything at all that you can
give us in terms of the tone of that
call or the length of the call i mean
the topics that you laid out
at boom boom boom were all pretty it
seemed like a quite
difficult conversation for the russian
president perhaps
i'm just wondering if you can give us
any sort of sense of color about
how it went well i'm not in the business
of reading out anything the russians are
doing
as i know you're not exactly asking but
sort of um
i will say that president biden uh had
clear objectives that he wanted to get
across during that call
um he has never held back as it relates
to uh president putin or
um his concerns about um the actions
of um of the russian uh government
and he certainly conveyed that clearly
during the call
as you know there's also a review that's
underway about a range of activities
that is being overseen by his national
security team
and he touched on a number of those
issues during that call but i don't have
anything more for you i'm sure
i'm sure the kremlin is happy to give
you a readout of how
how well president putin thinks the call
went uh go ahead
and another question is just on
immigration um
a federal judge in texas has blocked um
your 100-day deportation
pause oh i just wanted to see how that's
impacting the biden agenda and if there
is any way
a reason for perhaps a delay in an
immigration eo that we've been expecting
no i will say um i know we had a
statement on
on the specific case you referenced
which i'm happy to circle back with you
on it if you haven't received it
um uh in terms of our overarching agenda
and approach to immigration
you know there was an early and uh and
draft version
of the of our what our executive order
uh
plan and schedule looked like um and
that was early and was draft and was not
accurate but i will
tell you get some sleep this weekend
we'll have more to say next week on
immigration um
the president will uh so we'll have uh
more to report out to you
uh in the next couple days
um i was curious some of my colleagues
have earlier been asking you about
reconciliation and sort of the tension
between
moving quickly within this legislative
agenda versus sort of a longer
um period of negotiation and i do wonder
with this last week
we did have a senator leahy in the
hospital on senator mark warner and
you know quarantined because of covid
there's a pandemic going on
you have the slimmest possible majority
of the senate
is there any sort of when you look at
the health situation is there any sense
that perhaps
you know moving along quickly while you
still have the majority might be the
better move
well i've watched senator leahy in
action for quite some time
and uh he has been continues to be an
advocate as we know for justice for
equality
and uh i um you know he's pretty wily
and fierce
so we're pretty confident we're gonna be
working with him for a while and as you
know he's resting at home and we wish
him
we wish him our best but i would say the
president came
into office knowing he was going to have
a slim majority
and that it would be essential to work
with
both democrats and republicans and that
it would be
extremely challenging if not nearly
impossible
to get a big bold uh work
done on behalf of the american people
without working with both parties and
that's exactly why he has himself
had a number of engagements and calls
with members of congress democrats and
republicans
and why he has asked his team to do
exactly that as well so
we've known uh of course even before uh
even before the election in georgia we
thought the
there wouldn't even be a slim majority
we would be in the minority so
you know he's been planning for that and
we've been planning for that uh
through the course of the last several
months uh go ahead
and just i'm following up on immigration
um i
understand what you're saying about the
document that's out there uh with some
executive orders and and dates but the
chief of staff
also indicated that immigration would be
coming by february 1st which i believe
is monday
so are the immigration executive orders
coming on monday
and is this is there some uh desire to
wait until the secretary
is confirmed for the executive orders or
can you give us
any more spend some more light on this
uh no i would say
as you guys may know from doing your own
planning with long-term
enterprise stories sometimes things
change and uh
things change in communications planning
and what day you're going to put
information out
and there's a range of reasons for that
but i would say stay tuned we'll have
more to say next week
it's monday or not just sometime next
week it will be next week
one of the executive orders that we're
talking about a plan for family
reunification
at the border and that's one obviously
there's many but that's one that a lot
of people are waiting to kind of hear
what that plan is is that something we
should expect
well the president uh talked about his
commitment to
putting together a commission for
reunifying families he remains committed
to that
and we'll have more to share on that
soon um go ahead
back thank you so much gentlemen raquel
krahanger from tv global brazil
i have two questions going back to the
climate crisis
during the campaign president biden
warned of economic consequences
if brazil did not reduce deforestation
on the amazon
i'm wondering what kind of consequences
he's considering
if he could hurt for example the trade
negotiations with brazil
or the oecd support
well uh we just announced yesterday that
we're going to be doing a climate
uh summit coming up in the next couple
of months and of course this is a big
priority
for president biden and that's why he
asked
his good friends former secretary kerry
to lead our climate
international effort and certainly
brazil will be a key
partner in that but in terms of
what those negotiations and discussions
look like it's a little too early
for that at this point and i'd certainly
send you to the state department and
secretary kerry's office for more
details
so just a follow-up did he invite the
brazilian president will he invite for
the summit
and is also president uh biting still
planning to label countries
uh as climate outlaws and if so would
brazil be part of this list
well we're not quite there yet given we
just announced it there haven't been
invites or anything that went out
um but we're happy to keep everybody
updated and certainly
um as the united states is a large
emitter uh so is brazil so is china's or
many large
countries and large economies and we all
have a role to play in addressing this
crisis
one more question when does president
biden
think he will be able to start doing
or he'll do his first uh international
trip
and where would be the first place uh he
would go
i don't have anything to preview or
predict for you at this point as you
know we haven't done any domestic travel
yet given covid
um so i i certainly don't have any
predictions about a foreign trip
go ahead sabrina uh any question on her
confirmation hearing
yesterday uh u.n ambassador designate
linda thomas greenfield
said she believed that bds the boycott
divestment sanctions movement to
pressure israel
is unacceptable and borders on or verges
on anti-semitism is that a
characterization that the white house
shares when it comes to the bds movement
i don't have anything more for you on
kind of our position it's i think been
this
the president has spoken to this as a
candidate and prior as vice president
um but i don't have anything new um and
i'm happy to get back to you if there's
anything i can get you from the national
security team go ahead
thank you rob carly with the washington
examiner um just to actually follow up
on that linda thomas springfield
uh also said she would be standing
against the unfair
targeting of israel the relentless
resolutions that are proposed against
israel on 30
is that the position of the white house
is israel after all is in violation of
international law illegally occupies the
west bank
do you believe it's unfairly talented
you know i didn't see her full
uh hearing yesterday actually i didn't
see any of her hearing i'm happy to
review it and take a look and see if
there's more
we can speak to from our end back to the
executive orders
the questions we were discussing at the
start um so i'm still trying to sort of
reconcile this
daily i think we're at 26 executive
orders now and reconcile that with the
the campaign rhetoric because um in
october
joe biden said there were limitations on
the use of executive
actions things he can't do by executive
order
unless you're a dictator we're a
democracy we need consensus
i i i think you said earlier that some
of these executive orders were being
used to
um roll back some of the immoral things
that the previous administration had
done if you're calling these things
immoral is that seeking consensus and
unity
and then also i mean does it suggest
that president biden sees himself as
perhaps a benevolent
dictator well rob i'm sure this wasn't
your intention but i think you took the
president's comments a bit out of
context he was asked about tax reform
and and whether that could be done via
executive order during the interview
with george stephanopoulos which you're
referring to
well i think that i think the question
is pretty important context for
everybody
and he said no and the president also
said during an interview with columnist
uh back in december that he didn't think
executive action should be used for
everything and that certainly is his
point of view
but there are steps including
overturning some of the
harmful detrimental and yes immoral
actions of the prior administration that
he felt he could not wait
to to overturn and that's exactly what
he did
now any historian will tell you that he
walked into the presidency at one of the
most difficult moments in history
that required additional executive
action in order to
take get immediate relief to the
american people but he believes
as is as his law is everybody knows how
bill becomes a law uh is that
in order to make action and policy
permanent you need to work with congress
that's why he's also proposed a coveted
relief package
a big bold package some some say very
big um i agree with that
um and also an immigration bill he is
not he's not held back
or delayed putting forward legislation
either so uh
he's going to use the levers that every
president in history has used executive
actions
but he also feels it's important to work
with congress and not just one party but
both parties to get things done
go ahead in the back thank you jen a
couple of questions one technical
question on the eos sign today
does the does the eo on aca open the
marketplace to non-citizens to
legal residents or um undocumented
immigrants that may be able to benefit
from
the extra care it doesn't change the
requirements
um for a qualifying for the affordable
care act it opens it up
for three months for people who would be
already eligible for the affordable care
act so
but obviously there are um you know the
the
uh health and human services team will
continue to look for ways to expand
access
i will say you didn't ask this but this
is a common question so i'm just going
to proactively answer it
that uh we do feel as an administration
that ensuring that
all people uh in the united states
undocumented immigrants as well
of course should receive access to a
vaccine um because that
uh one is morally right but also uh
ensures that people in the country are
also safe
that was my second question how are you
guiding these things actually yes
okay the common one yeah how are you
guiding the states if
any in any way to get those undocumented
communities to come forward to get
vaccinated many of them in the states
don't have any way to prove
that they're residents of those states
in order to go to their local
clinics and improve uh residency to get
the vaccine so how are you
working with the states to get that done
it's challenging we've talked about this
a bit in here i mean there's obviously
vaccine hesitancy which certainly exists
in communities of
undocumented immigrants and the concern
of what it will mean for their
status and uh but we are focused on
ensuring we get the vaccine out broadly
um and to
communities across the country because
that will make um
the american people safer and it's
something we have to be both creative
about
aggressive about ambitious about is one
of the reasons we need additional
funding
through the american rescue plan but one
also one of the reasons why we plan to
have an aggressive public
education campaign to help embolden and
empower local doctors and authorities
i may ask one more on cuba do you guys
plan on
starting walking back all of those
restrictions that were put into place
under
the trump administration after the obama
administration had opened things up with
cuba
well our cuba policy is governed by
two principles um first support for
democracy and human rights
uh that will be at the core of our
efforts second is
americans especially cuban americans are
the best ambassadors for
freedom in cuba so we'll review the
trump administration policies
um as we are in a number of other areas
of national security
with an eye to ensure ensuring that our
approach is aligned with that but
uh you know we'll take our own path i
don't i don't have anything to predict
for you at this point in time
go ahead alex um i wanted to clarify
something we talked a little bit about
uh the administration's stance on school
reopenings yeah sure
um so i was like i wasn't really clear
on that so
i got a little better information
indicated that uh
he believes that the administration
believes that schools need more funding
for them to be safe enough to reopen for
students to go back but
there's been a number of studies
including the recent one out of the cdc
that have shown evidence that schools
are perfectly safe for students to go
back and and there were recommendations
that they should go back
so this seems like a bit of a dispute
between teachers unions and sort of data
and the science so where does the
administration stand in
that dispute well first let me be
absolutely clear
president biden wants schools to open
and he wants them to stay open
uh because it's obviously very
disruptive for families that i'm a
mother
you know for anyone who has kids for
kids to come in and out of school
but that means making sure as you said
that every school is able to have the
equipment and resources to open safely
not just rural schools or private
schools which often is where a lot of
the
school reopenings and schools staying
open is happening it's a more of a
challenge in public schools where they
don't have that funding from
tuition or smaller populations where
it's easier
to put in place the actions needed to
keep the schools
open but the cdc study which i know has
gotten received a lot of attention
was um based on uh kind of an area that
was more rural
in wisconsin it was not and i think what
dr wolenski has said is that
i think she said this on cnn last night
is that for areas where they are more
populated where schools where there are
there's a lot more foot traffic
that there are going to need to be a lot
of steps put in place
in order to make the schools reopening
safe but
we are committed to doing that that's
why the president signed an executive
order
last week supporting the safe reopening
of schools
it requires the departments of education
and cdc to provide evidence-based
guidance so
that will include things like testing
smaller class sizes more ventilation
better cleaning ppe
strong state and local public health
guidance but we want to
provide that clarity from the federal
government because there's a lot of
confusion and public schools
especially don't know what steps they
need to take how to ensure they're safe
those are all good decisions that are
going to be made locally but we want to
give them the guidance
that's in process our team is working on
that dr wolinski the cdc and our health
experts and we hope to have more
specifics soon maybe two more questions
go ahead
so american savings rate is has been up
throughout the pandemic um and so i'm
wondering
why give all americans a fourteen
hundred dollar check and why not means
test
for uh the release that your your
administration is talking about
well first the proposed checks i mean
the the the
um have the same criteria as the package
that received broad bipartisan support
in december right so
approximately the 1400 checks would go
to families making approximately a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year there's a scaling up
as i think you're referencing up to
about three hundred thousand dollars i
think you are aware of this but just for
everybody else
um and you know there has been some
questions about that
president biden our economic team we're
open to discussing that
but we want to ensure that the families
that need relief that need assistance
get it um and i would say at a time
where we saw the economic data today uh
and
this was reflected in brian diese's
statement it was worse than
uh any one week i don't want to misquote
myself here uh
than that we saw during the great
recession i mean people are suffering
thous millions of people are out of work
people don't know how to put food on the
table
uh these challenges are real we it's the
data shows it but we also see
long lines for food pantries uh we see
uh you know people who are out of work
and don't know what they're gonna do
to make ends meet and so that's tangible
that's real and
we want the the pac the packets is gonna
need to be big and bold to address that
since we've been talking about women's
health and access to abortion today
does the administration plan to uh
suspend the requirement that the
medical medication abortion pill be
picked up in person
i know that that's something that
advocates have been pushing for after
the reversal under the trump
administration
yeah i i've certainly seen some
reporting questions about that um
i'll have to talk to our uh health team
about that specifically
um can i ask one more about the travel
restrictions
sure go ahead and kill them a lot of our
viewers are
asking if there will be any kind of
consideration for
waivers for students or unmarried couple
appearances
since that is now the requirement for
testing and quarantine
well uh i know there's been a lot of
coverage of this and questions because
these are people's lives and human
beings who are missing their loved ones
and their family members
and just to restate what the
requirements are now so spouses of
american citizens
and lawful permanent residents are able
to travel under
uh these restrictions we've put in place
on international travel
although they have to take part in the
mandatory pre-departure testing that
applies to everyone and we are reviewing
and assessing i should say um how uh
students and unmarried couples and uh
how we can proceed with that moving
forward i don't have anything to preview
for you but we're certainly our team is
looking into that criteria why
countries with high numbers like russia
or india
or mexico are not in the least well our
our health and medical team takes a
close look at
what restrictions we need to put in
place in order to keep the american
people safe and
that's how we review it it's not about
geopolitics i
was at times in the prior administration
that's not how we approach things it's
about
where we need to put restrictions in
place to keep the american people safe
i promise caitlyn should get the next so
just to get some clarification on the
cdc study about schools being
good to reopen precautions or taking is
the white house position that
it needs to be further studied since
you're citing just the one school
in wisconsin or does the white house
agree with the recommendations from the
cdc about schools reopening
well the cdc hasn't issued the formal
recommendations or requirements on how
all schools across the country can open
they did a report as they do reports
frequently um
uh based on uh an area in wisconsin
important in interesting data no doubt
but it that
is not reflective of every school
district and community
uh in the country and so they will be
coming out with more specific
requirements or more specific i should
say guidelines uh for the public because
there are schools that are in much more
highly populated areas
there are schools that have far more
kids in classrooms farmer kids
walking into the school and they want to
ensure that there's
clarity on testing needs class size
needs
uh you know public health guidance that
that people can
abide by but you know their
recommendation is that
k-12 schools should be the last settings
to close
after all of these mitigation measures
have been employed
employed and the first to reopen so we
are all want schools to
to open and be open for good um what
what i'm reflecting on or what i'm
trying to clarify i guess is that
um you know schools and cities are
dealing with different challenges than
schools in rural communities and schools
in wisconsin may be dealing in different
challenges than schools in
you know you know downtown atlanta right
so
uh there needs to be um kind of the cdc
will issue
more specific guidelines um soon uh
their focus on it now
okay and last question on this so
president biden has said he wants all
schools to reopen
in his first 100 days is that still the
goal if
congress does not pass this proposal
which has the money for schools which
brian klein and others have said is what
they believe schools need to reopen
i sense skepticism about the bill
getting passed we don't
feel that uh look i think the reason i
know that's your job um
look i think caitlin one of the reasons
why we're so focused on the american
rescue plan and getting it urgently
passed through congress
is because we need this funding in order
for schools to reopen
and for them to have the support to
ensure that they have proper ventilation
better cleaning
testing ppe that's a key component of
the package
and that's one of the reasons we're not
going to negotiate out that versus
vaccine funding or
or you know unemployment insurance
because that's a key component
and we need that to ensure that schools
will have the resources across the
country
to be able to uh reopen and that's
exactly what the president wants to
happen
thank you jen thank you oh okay we're
good
she was very patient go ahead thank you
um i just wonder if there is a general
sense of frustration just about the pace
of things
um you know given the vaccine
distribution you know some of what you
inherited from the trump administration
trying to roll out executive orders um
you know working with congress and
sort of having some lawmakers raise
concerns is it harder to change things
than you all thought it would be
uh i i i'm only laughing because we're
on our eighth day here
so you know and in that period of time
the president has signed
multiple executive orders he has
proposed several
comprehensive bills he's had many
conversations with members of congress
about the urgency of getting things done
and i will say in those conversations
there is an
understanding and agreement about the
urgency of addressing these issues so
no we're we're actually pretty uh
hopeful and optimistic about the
uh opportunity and the ability to work
with democrats and republicans to get
uh packages through to help uh bring
relief to the american public but
we also recognize that uh members of
congress have uh they're not wall
flowers they have different points of
view they have lots of ideas
they're going to bring those forward
we're hearing them and
we're just eager to move things forward
as quickly as we can but we're on day
eight so we are
confident uh we're still on a pretty
rapid pace here
thanks everyone uh i appreciate all of
you i'll be in my office uh thanks for
your time and we'll do this again
tomorrow
do
you